[Applause]
it is true though
sorry to cut you but like about how the
democrats operate in that way like i
think a perfect example was that [ __ ]
horribly embarrassing like kinte clock
photo dude white people are tap dancing
for your vote right now
how does it feel how does it feel how
does it feel well
i mean it feels good there you go did
you get one of those
no no but it only feels good because
it's like we're finally being
acknowledged
the way they're going about it is funny
so it's more so it feels good because
it's entertaining
but it's like hey any awareness to
improving the way
my livelihood i'm all on board yo white
people really treating black people like
an angry girlfriend
washing your [ __ ] feet no i was like
is there anything i could do
how are you feeling like i got you babe
watch whatever you want to watch
like yeah but it's like hey you want to
watch 13th tonight
i'm gonna give it a shot let's just stop
on the police yeah but it's like
it's like you guys they're treated
they're talking to them like
how you would deal with an angry
girlfriend who
previous boyfriends have been beating
her up yeah so it's like she's more on
edge she's more like that yeah
so it's like you need to cuddle a little
bit yeah but what was that foot rub [ __ ]
baby
foot [ __ ] can someone explain what
that foot rub [ __ ]
how racist so for anybody who doesn't
know what's going on apparently there
was some protests where like
black people were able to sit down and
then white people were washing their
feet or like rubbing their feet have you
guys seen this inventory going around
yeah it's a thing to see that yeah
reparations have gone down so much for
black people
you guys are yeah you guys were promised
a lot of [ __ ] and now you're just
getting foot rubbed
yeah no but like for me when i look at
that i'm like how
racist do you have to be yeah man that
you are going to
rub someone's feet so that they don't
know how racist you are
because nobody that actually sees black
people as equal if a black guy came up
to me
like yo you're white i'm black rub my
feet
i mean i will beat your [ __ ] ass
right now
if you weren't scary and black you're
not about to watch your white ass
no but for real like are you [ __ ]
kidding me talk to tell me to rub your
feet
yo maybe that's why white people want to
rub black people's feet because that's
the whitest part of their body
yeah hey i'll touch the white part yeah
like yo but
isn't that crazy though like i couldn't
believe it and i really think there's
some like deep down [ __ ] racism and
guilt about your racism nobody that
treats someone equally
would do that to themselves i don't know
if it yeah racism i just think it's like
um they don't know what to do like you
were saying that's an overreach
it's really simple not knowing what to
do so like okay
if this is going to show that i'm not
racist like i'll do it
but would you do that like what if
indians were like you've met black
people you've made fun of us for years
rub our feet nah nah like robin akash's
feet it's
they just like you said it's all over i
also don't really know it's crazy
so it's a thing that's an interesting
point you bring up but
the point is what do you mean actually
that's why black people see indians as
equal there's no way you all look down
on it there's no way you could look at
somebody that athletically inferior
and say that's my equal enough for them
maybe black people as a whole maybe like
i do
but maybe we're like um
my dog is like we're like golden doodles
to them like we're exotic you know what
i
me don't do that hey don't do that hey
bro
don't do that don't don't don't make my
dog indian bro
your dog's indian hey hey don't do that
bro
hey hey don't do that why what's wrong
with the dog being indian what what's
wrong with the dog being in no i named
my
name tikki see
no it's actually ticking masala but
dinky wiki works
cute no not my dog but for real uh don't
do that bro don't don't don't
don't do that to myself
oh what does that mean a hindu it means
uh
i take [ __ ] no problem
you gotta do what you gotta do yo this
picture okay so back to the picture with
the
scarves i gotta give credit to this
[ __ ] nancy pelosi
this [ __ ] smart bro she she's the only
democrat
that knows how to play trump's game
she's the
only democrat that understands the most
important thing
is the conversation not the content
so she's like yeah put all this dumb
[ __ ] on we're gonna go take a knee we're
gonna look absolutely ridiculous they're
gonna make memes about it they're going
to do everything and the conversation
will be about
us and what we want to get accomplished
or not even what we want to
accomplish about us not trump she's
taking attention away from trump as long
as we're talking about them
we're not talking about trump and trump
dominates the news cycle because we're
talking about him
if i got to give her credit she's
takashi bro
this is the she's akashi i didn't even
look at it that way i'm not that's
bro to cancer six nine dog pelos
i'm telling you this girl is she knows
what she's doing